[Music]
welcome my name
is will i am one of the admission
officers here at the stanford graduate
school of business
i'm joined by my colleagues which we'll
do a brief introduction
uh shortly but i want to make sure that
we're able to orient
ourselves to what's going to be
happening today this
is our very first application week and
we
are so excited about having the
opportunity
to really dive into some of the topics
that we get a lot of questions about
in our information sessions we typically
do a high level
overview and there's so much room for us
to
get into those leads help answer some of
the questions you have
and really unveil kind of some of that
mystery that often surrounds the
admissions process
today we're going to be focusing on
testing transcripts and academic history
kind of
broadly as those also sit under the
umbrella of intellectual vitality
what does that all mean i'll cover that
in this introduction of what is the
holistic review process
from there we'll do our panelist
introductions and these are two panels
that i'm so excited to spend time with
today
we'll have a little bit of a moderated
question and answer session
conversational in nature and then we'll
turn to your questions
so today our goal is to help you better
understand
testing transcripts and academics within
the
kind of understanding of the admissions
process here at the gsd
our other goal and it's maybe the goal
i'm even more excited about is being
able to share tips
best practices and things to consider
to help you put your best foot forward
when it comes to applying to business
school
and hopefully here at the gsb all right
so the holistic review process what
is it it is something that might be
a little bit of a foreign concept to
some folks like in fact
admissions is often a foreign concept to
people but the
holistic review process is kind of the
philosophy that we use as we're
reviewing applications
here's a definition that i really
appreciate
um holistic as a philosophy is
characterized by comprehension of the
parts of something
as intimately interconnected and
explicable only by reference to the
whole
for us that means we are making our
admissions decisions on the entirety of
the pieces that you send to us
as we're thinking about that evaluation
process
a couple questions right off the bat
that we often get
so we do not use a formula an equation
or algorithm in any of our admissions
decisions
kind of in line with like hey what are
there
are any kind of structures or funneling
systems that happen
there are no benchmarks no cutoffs and
no quotas of any kind in our evaluation
process either
we often get the question i hear or is
it true that you only take
you know x amount of people from my
industry or x amount of people from my
country
and that is not true we are evaluating
you as an individual
within the greater context of where
you're coming from because you'll see
like
two lines down from here context matters
and no one part of the application
matters necessarily more than any other
so today we are going to step away from
the questions of
here is my gpa here is my testing am i
competitive or not
and really kind of shift the focus to
think about
okay so what is helpful for me to know
about
so that i can put my best foot forward
that's why we start talking about
context and i have a feeling we'll
we'll talk a lot about this year and
different ways for you to let us know
about about the context
of either your academic intellectual and
or other achievements
so what are we looking for so i gave you
kind of that philosophical rundown
but we're looking for things in three
buckets first
intellectual vitality this is the one
where we're really going to be talking
about today
testing transcripts academics as a
marker as some markers
of potentially many of that intellectual
vitality
demonstrated leadership potential and
personal qualities and contributions
rather than go through all three right
now i highly encourage that you check
out our mba admissions evaluation
criteria webpage
there's a lot of really great
information there and really accessible
language
rhetorical questions on intellectual
vitality that can help you
uncover what are some of the ways this
might come to life for you
and in the case of demonstrated
leadership potential we actually outline
some of the different types of
leadership competencies that you might
be exhibiting in your everyday
where do we find this throughout your
whole application
i like to use this visual as a
representation that
each part of the application helps us
understand one
piece of who you are it is almost like
that analogy of the three wise men or
through wise people who were touching
different parts of the elephant
and each one because they couldn't see
someone was touching a foot
someone was touching the trunk someone
was touching the tail they all had
different interpretations of it
but once they were able to take their
blindfolds off and see the entirety of
what it was
there was so much more and a very
different outcome than what you might be
what they might have thought before
that's similar to the application
process
we are taking a look at everything you
submit to get a better sense of who
you are how you might show up in our
classrooms and in our community
so with that preface i'm gonna stop
share so we'll be able to focus our
attention on our conversation today
um and if we could start um with
christine
we'll have you start and if you can
introduce yourself and
what is something meaningful for you
about our line of work about
a profession of admissions sure thanks
will hi everyone my name is christine
and i'm one of the admission officers
here at stanford's graduate school of
business
and i've been working in nba admissions
for many years now and i think one of
the things that's so rewarding
about the work that we do is that we are
hopefully
like we are today spending some time
educating and raising awareness about
the opportunities
in higher education uh for everyone so
no matter what background you're coming
from what academic experiences or
professional experiences you've had
helping to highlight what a graduate
degree and particularly an mba degree
can do
for anyone because there are so many
options once you're armed with this
degree for what you can do so i love
getting to spend time
one-on-one with applicants and admitted
students and talking about
what they want to do next and how the
mba from stanford might help them get
there
and allison what quick introduction and
what's something about this work that's
meaningful for you
hi everybody i'm allison happy to be
with you this morning
um in the context of learning i think
what i love is not only when i'm reading
each of your application
i feel like i'm opening a book on
someone's life
but i also feel like i'm getting a
window to the world
because through all of your essays and
experiences from different industries
and career stages and life experiences
and all over the world i just feel like
i learn so much
about the world um through your your
personal journeys
nice and for those of you one more time
my name is will
and one of the things that fuels me is
being able to be
a part of your educational journeys
whether you end up applying and coming
to stanford
applying elsewhere or deciding to go on
another life path like these are things
that
how can i help you like realize and see
what options are out there and choose
what's best for you
i think that's something that keeps me
going every day
so let's turn to the topic at hand we
are going to be
talking about testing transcripts
academics and
i would like to actually start um with
this idea of stats there's a lot of
tension
and anxiety out there about hey the
school's
um average gpa is this the school's
testing averages that
can we unpack a little bit together like
what do those stats
mean how to interpret it and like should
someone count themselves
out of applying if they don't meet those
numbers
so any like initial thoughts clearly i
have a lot of feelings about this
um let me start um i would just say
there's such a
over um our our potential applicants
tend to obsess
too much about the numbers and you know
gmat scores gre scores
your gpa and please know that we don't
look at
any of you as a number and um not only
are we forming a class
of students but we're also forming a
community so
you are much much more than you know
whatever your gpa
is or whatever your gre score is and as
will referred
earlier there's no no minimum scores
there's no target scores that we're
looking for
and then oh guy question i was just
going to build on allison's
mention i know so often as you're
starting your research and you're
learning about different schools one of
the first
places you visit will be that class
profile for different programs
and i would just encourage you all not
to anchor too much
on what the averages or the medians
might be there because you must remember
that's
kind of just that middle ground there
are going to be students at both ends of
that spectrum and it's a pretty wide
spectrum
at most schools so don't necessarily you
know count yourself
out just because you may not be
necessarily close to one number because
allison said there are so many different
uh things to consider and as will
mention there are so many places we go
looking for that intellectual vitality
and i guess the other thing to remember
too is that class profile you're looking
at that's just one particular year
so they change from year to year because
our students change from year to year
yeah that's true and so maybe the
natural extension of that question
is if we're not anchoring so those
numbers are
a figment of who ends up getting
admitted as opposed to
targets that we're trying to reach
that's like a very different philosophy
um so as we think about
testing transcripts like how do we use
those in the
evaluation process um can you shed any
light on
that piece of it allison i'll kick us
off and maybe you'll
you'll add in if i've forgotten anything
so i think it's important to remember
that when we're taking a look at your
application as alice had mentioned we're
building this class we're shaping a
community here on campus but that is all
around the idea of business school as
well mentioned
we are here focusing on your education
and we ultimately want to make sure that
students are joining us who will be able
to thrive
in the classroom so one of the things
that we are looking at with your
transcripts and your test scores
is your ability to handle some of the
quantitative coursework that you'll be
facing
in an mba program so that doesn't
necessarily mean that you have to come
from a quantitative background in fact
many of our students don't
so it's just a matter of where you may
have had some exposure to those concepts
in different places whether it be
in the classroom through tests or even
in your workplace so again it's not only
limited to your tests and transcripts at
some point but we do go there as a first
place to start to get a sense of
what quantitative exposure you've had so
far
and i would just add to bring us back to
the evaluation criteria and the
one first one we'll mention was
intellectual vitality
there's all sorts of ways to show that
and i think
a lot of us know people that we've been
in class with where maybe they had
really high grades but they didn't
necessarily
you know have intellectual curiosity and
i think the opposite is true
you know we may see somebody with um
uh lower you know scores but maybe
they did original research as an
undergraduate which is pretty amazing
or maybe um at work you know they wrote
kind of a white paper
that that took some research and and was
beyond so they're
you know when we talk about the holistic
evaluation we're
diving deeper than just your your you
know the
the scores and the numbers and we're
looking for examples of
of intellectual vitality
i'm actually going to jump into the q a
box because there is
a question here from andre from serbia
and hope i'm sorry if i mispronounced
your name but
they would like to know about the gmat
gre kind of within that umbrella
of intellectual vitality and i think
this would be
a really great place to unpack
intellectual vitality itself um
i like to think of it as like what's
your relationship with knowledge
um just the way allison was talking
about what are some of those things that
kind of spark your curiosity
i kind of tried to slip in a little bit
of a
uh kind of easy intro for all of you to
start thinking about what are the things
that insight
excite you in our introductions um but
allison christine any thoughts on kind
of
intellectual vitality overall and kind
of what are those pieces that
you were to explain a little bit about
markers that you might
succeed in the classroom but any
thoughts on iv
intellectual vitality um broadly i guess
another example that comes to mind in
terms of intellectual curiosity is
you may have been someone who really
sought out
really hard classes in in university and
classes
you know outside of your major and you
didn't do particularly well in them
but again there's the grade and then
there's this pattern of seeing that you
were
often um you know taking harder classes
or ranging
you know far from from your major and um
so again i think for for me a lot of it
is
um curiosity and the um
uh the uh kind of energy to follow that
curiosity even if sometimes
it's it's difficult yeah and i would say
sometimes it's not only just about
the difficulty level of a class but if
you were a double major or you had a
minor or two minors
uh that was a way that during your
undergraduate experience you were ex
expressing and exploring your
intellectual curiosity uh you know
sometimes that surfaced because you were
just
curious and you weren't sure what the
right path might be uh others were
really clear
and were very you know particular about
which classes they chose to participate
in
so those are all subtle things in the
transcript that we're looking for but i
would also take
take us out of the transcript for a
minute one of the other places that that
intellectual curiosity
will surface for us is actually through
your extracurricular activities
if you have hobbies or different
organizations that you might be involved
with outside of work and outside of the
classroom
uh that can actually pop there too
because oftentimes you're drawn to
different
uh you know activities because you have
a particular interest or passion in it
so it does surface in many places oh you
can also say that for
for work too like what are some insights
you might have had that have shaped the
way a project
or outcome has turned out um it's this
broad eye
concept of ideas maybe and what are
the ideas that excite you knowing that
some ideas are going to be explored in
the classroom
and some might actually be more exciting
and dynamic
in that professional realm so really
thinking broadly about that so
love that and i we actually already
started to go into
transcripts and as someone that i highly
respect and invites like
conversation like this let's go there um
so um let's talk about the transcripts
allison you
started talking about gpa and looking
beyond just that single number
gpa is a single data point that
actually doesn't tell me much when i'm
reading an application
the transcript itself as a whole is so
much more interesting and has so much
more data and information about you to
it um can we talk a little bit about
how we look at kind of the coursework
trends anything like that within the um
the transcript itself
yeah well we talked some about um
taking classes outside your major i
think uh we do look at the rigor of your
major
and so you know you may have been
pre-med or
you know electrical engineering major
and
so you know the gpa may be lower
but uh i guess what i'm saying is we
look at the context
of uh we look at your your performance
within the context so maybe
um tough major maybe you were the first
person in your family to ever go to
college
um maybe um you your family immigrated
to the states so
your your your english isn't your first
language so
we really look at the broader context in
terms of things that
may have contributed or affected your
your performance
i'm actually going to expand that
context even further because i know
there's additional contacts that we also
consider
and that is what was happening in your
life outside of the classroom
so maybe you were on a varsity sports
team and we know that
the time commitment that is required uh
if you're a member of a sports team
maybe you were working part-time or in
some cases maybe full-time while you
were in school and that might have
impacted the amount of time you were
able to devote
to your studies and your coursework
maybe you were working on campus
serving as a teaching assistant or a
research assistant so
understanding the context within which
that you were pursuing your education
is also really important for us to
understand
and i guess i i want to um mention too
that um you know why is any of this
important in terms of your grades i mean
as christine mentioned of course we want
you not to just to survive
here but thrive here but it's not like
um we want these grades because we're
we are focused on your achievement
um a lot of the learning here at
stanford is from each other
so we care a lot about if you're the
kind of person who
loves ideas is going to challenge each
other
and the professor inside the classroom
outside the classroom
so a lot of that has to do not just with
oh
we want you to you know be a high
achiever but we want you to be an
active contributor not only to your own
education but to your classmates
yeah i think on that front something
that i think of a lot about is
if i were in an applicant shoes if i was
applying to business school
um i know my academic history and i you
know i could have prepared better
and so i think a lot about or like i
could you know college was a different
time in my life
so i actually think a lot about am i
kind
is that who i am or are there things
that
we can do or that someone out there can
do um
to show that they have demonstrated or
they have those abilities
and can demonstrate it in like a
classroom or learning environment
i think this might be the first time
we've ever actually gone
into um tips best practices
things folks out there might can do um
to go out and um kind of take ownership
of their journey for lack of better
words
and i wanna before we go into this space
i do wanna put out the disclaimer that
we don't necessarily recommend that you
do one thing versus another
but really take that step back to see
okay what is realistic for
for me given um whatever's around me
resources
time accessibility um so again this is
not going to be a set of hard and fast
rules but rather things that we might
have seen
um and maybe ways of thinking about it
uh that can help you even beyond just uh
the application process
so we've read a lot of applications
what are some of the things that either
we've seen or kind of
could think about for folks who are who
want to beef up that kind of academic
preparedness
so in terms of that well where i think
you might be going here is if you're say
coming from a social sciences background
you're an english major a history major
uh maybe you didn't really need to take
too many math or science classes
and so you know we are going to be
looking for your quantitative
exposure you're not required to take
pre-coursework before
you join the mba but some people do find
it helpful so you may want to take
advantage of all of those amazing
online resources local community
colleges there are a lot of ways to gain
exposure to some of those concepts
but it is entirely up to you again not a
requirement
for our application process you should
check for other schools that might have
them but for us it's really about just
expanding your mind getting comfortable
with some of these concepts
and some of those you know do come with
fees but many of those can actually be
accessed for free
online now so there is a way to kind of
gain that exposure and we have seen some
people do it
before they apply others don't do it
before they apply but they make the
choice to actually gain some of that
experience before they start the program
so in the summer leading up to school
sometimes they'll take advantage of some
of those online resources or taking a
class before they start the mba
yeah so christine what happens if like
i'm signed up for a class
like that is after the decision uh or
after the application deadline like how
should i convey that should i convey it
is that important
absolutely it's certainly worth
mentioning so when in doubt
whenever you feel like there might be
some piece of your intellectual or
academic journey or story
that can't be clearly explained or
expressed in the application that is
where the additional
information section will come in in your
application which is not
meant to be just a whole separate essay
but rather a place as a catch-all really
for anything that you just need to
inform us about so it could be a single
bullet point or sentence that says
i've registered to take this class and
i'll be starting it and it could be
after the application deadline this is
also a place where
if you had any struggles or challenges
during undergrad
either an overall gpa or maybe just a
particular class
if you feel like there's additional
context that you need to explain to us
for where those grades might have come
from you can use that additional
information section there we've
definitely seen that utilized for anyone
who's
explaining whether it was you know an
illness or an injury that may have
prevented them from taking a test
and that affected their final grade in a
class that you can let us know there
there is a space so
you don't leave us to our own devices to
make up stories you can tell us exactly
what happened
yeah and i would encourage folks to
think about
if you're going to do any of this
academic preparation
uh maybe it's just been a long time
since you've had to do
either intensive reading or writing
to think about preparing for the mba
itself
you know work towards a goal that you'll
be able to hit the ground running once
you're at school
because that is going to help you
long-term as opposed to just taking a
class for the sake of applying
and i hope that mentality will set you
up better for
long-term success in terms of like what
classes
to think about you actually know your
kind of academic history the best and
this is where i would
encourage you to take that kind of step
back again
and take control of the narrative if you
know there's an area that you might have
struggled with in the past
that could be an area to think about uh
doing a little bit of additional work on
we talk a lot about quantitative
skills and the quantitative elements of
the business school experience
but i would also encourage folks to
practice
reading practice writing communication
and verbal skills are also going to be a
huge part of the mba experience i know
allison was just talking about
how do you challenge ideas and have
constructive dialogue
where there are differences of opinion
because that's
that's where learning happens i think
dean levin talks about
um learning happens when you embrace the
difference
and so how are we able to communicate
that
great so we covered a little bit about
transcripts so now can we let's shift
over to testing
like there's a lot of questions and even
a in our q a box about okay
the test score you get one one score
but there's also sub components can we
talk a little bit about that and
how that kind of factors in among the
other parts of the application i i guess
i'd start by just reminding people that
just like everything in the application
we keep telling you that we look at it
in context
same thing with the test scores so for
example
the verbal score we're not going to
expect as high a verbal score
for um a non-native speaker as a native
english speaker
of course with a quantitative score
if you were that history or english
major you may not and you probably won't
have as high a quant score
as that physics or engineering major so
we look at at uh each piece in context
um and and as will said you know there
there there's no no minimum score um but
i should say
with the english proficiency exams there
are hard minimums for
obvious reasons you need to be fluent in
english before you get here but with the
gmat gre no minimum
yeah and remind me allison those are
actually set by the university as a
whole
right correct for the english
proficiency right yeah
yeah but well since we're talking about
tests i'd love to remind everyone now
that whether we're speaking about the
gmat
and gre or the english language
proficiency exams
you all have options so we accept both
the gmat
and the gre and there are no preferences
between those two exams
so usually what i personally recommend
and speaking just for myself but
before you sign up to take one of the
tests you can take free practice
questions online with both tests
so you can get a sense and a feel for
what each test is like and if you find
that you might be scoring better on one
versus the other
maybe that's the test to consider and
that might be the one you want to take
if you think that'll give you the
opportunity to put your best foot
forward there
on a testing standpoint and when it
comes to the english language
proficiencies we accept three different
tests the toefl
the ielts and the pearson test of
english so yes there are minimums for
each of those that are set by stanford
university but again there are different
tests and ways of asking you those
questions
so you can be selective in terms of
which tests you're choosing to take
and we have a very wide range of scores
in the class
you will see um you know high average
scores
at stanford and it's not because we're
aiming for a particular score that those
averages tend to reflect
our applicant pool in terms of who
applies uh
but many times we've had people in the
class
uh into the 500s and
and i can remember one particular case
where we actually had someone in the
class who got a 450 gmat
now i'm not saying you should aim for a
450 gmat but the point was the person
um had you know quite a low score and
they did
perfectly fine
and so i think that also talk goes into
our conversation about the sub scores
one one of them again is not necessarily
more or less important than the other
and then we're looking across both your
academic history
as well as what are some of the things
you're doing in your workplace
i think that is somewhere that folks
don't often um
think about when we're thinking about
that intellectual vitality and what are
some of the skill sets and knowledge
sets that are going to help set you up
for success in business
school and that's actually one of the
questions here from yuzura
who's asking about those subsections um
and i can
like say that i have seen instances
where someone
did not have that many math courses in
their
academic background testing was fine
and in their workplace they were doing a
lot of
financial analysis modeling so it
demonstrated okay yes
this individual does have that
wherewithal to be able to thrive in
different
class settings um and in different
environments at business school so
thinking about it even holistically and
very broadly beyond just
here's that one section um and what does
that one thing tell us again it's like
no one pieces are like
entry gate but really we're looking at
the entirety of your application to find
things
um that's something too that your
recommender might mention
they might talk about uh you know
analytical projects you've done
or projects that required a lot of
reading and writing and and give us you
know
another data point about your
quantitative and verbal skills
okay and because i mentioned the word
holistic maybe a million times during
this conversation
then the question here there's actually
a question here from alex
about how much time does so does an
admission officer spend to holistically
evaluate a candidate of any thoughts
i ever thought but i i'm really curious
to hear what you have to what your
responses are
well you'll notice that christine and i
both have rather thick
glasses and that's no accident
over so many years of reading
absolutely and i would say you probably
saw me chuckle there when you were
asking the question because i think we
all
read at our own different personal
pieces
i know my my how much time it takes me
to read might change
depending on what time of day it is so
the most important thing for us is that
we are reviewing every piece of that
application
and some people might read a little
faster some might read a little slower
uh some people might read and then take
longer to really think
about you know making any decisions and
so we're all kind of working at our own
paces but we're all on that same mission
to
make sure we're treating every applicant
with full respect and reading every
every portion of that application before
reaching any conclusions
um so the actual number would probably
vary pretty widely depending on the day
or time of year even yeah and i would
go ahead go ahead allison i'm just going
to say for us it's sort of like peeling
back the onions so
for example if we do see a low gpa we're
going to be asking ourselves
you know why is that is there any
circumstances there is there any
countervailing evidence like you know
gmat score gre scored to
to mitigate the gpa or
or uh performance at work so
and my half joking half serious answer
is as long as it takes
some applications are pretty clear-cut
you're like oh here's someone
you know evidence is here it's clear
there's
shining recommendations okay here's
someone we might want to consider
those ones go quickly they're also
someone maybe the preparation is here
we're not seeing some of that
demonstrated leadership potential you
know so those might go quickly as well
and then the ones that take the longest
are often the ones that have the pieces
of contextual information or dots that
we need to do a little bit more
connecting
so that like as christine was saying
like we are giving
as fair and like like how can we best
honor
the entirety of this application to give
a fair assessment
and so it really does differ by
individual you know by
kind of environmental conditions and
also by application so
a couple of different factors there uh
but
at the end i actually really value and
appreciate
um our reading system and it's actually
one of the things that kind of
keeps me in this job is that we're able
to do things holistically
okay so
let's go into we're actually going to
start
leaning more into the q a box i think
there's some really great
content here um christine there there
was a question that i saw earlier about
deferred candidates like they still have
a chunk of their like senior year
usually left to go so
for our different candidates and
deferred admission that is when you're
applying in the final year of your
bachelor's or
um a grad program if you've gone all the
way through
um can you talk a little bit about how
we view those transcripts knowing that
there's gonna be a little bit a chunk of
them that's
not going to be full by the time they
apply absolutely
well and again we're going to use that
word context again it's about us
understanding what you've done with the
time you've had so far
so you know for students that have been
working for five years we'll have the
full
kind of past tense view of how you did
an undergrad with our deferred students
who might be applying during their
senior year we'll see how you've done in
your first three or three and a half
years
so we'll get a sense of the you know how
you performed
in the classroom most recently you'll be
able to take the tests
while you're still in that kind of study
mode while you're still a student and so
that will give us just kind of a moment
in time
understanding of how you've performed in
the classroom so our expectation then is
if that you're performing well now
hopefully you are preparing and will be
performing well two to four years from
now and you might be joining us in the
mba classroom
but it is just a piece and it is a
moment in time so like with all of our
applications these are just
some of the data that we're considering
when reviewing your entire application
and we will ask for that final
transcript
uh for that last semester uh you know in
the summer before you come so
um you know keep keep your grades
up and here's a tactical practical
question
so going into some of the logistics of
it and these questions from uh
konica um are we open to considering the
highest section scores from different
sittings or do we consider the overall
like a single sitting or the overall
highest
gmat gre good question
uh but officially we will need you to
report a single score
so from a single sitting so you may have
taken the test say two times
and you had a higher verbal on one and a
higher quant on other
you can't mix them together you'll have
to pick one of those overall scores to
report to us
uh in your application and you'll be
self-reporting in the application i
think i saw another question in that q a
box that what if i take the test and the
official scores may not be in in time
for the deadline
that's okay because you're
self-reporting on the application it's
okay if the official sports post
right after or a little after that
application deadline but
ultimately you can only there's only
space in the application to report
uh one full test score
here's a question from katarina and i
have to admit i
love this question i love when we're
able to
unpack and demystify and really add
information and meet to rumors that are
out there
and so here's one who um they've heard
from previous students that the bar is
much higher for international students
are the expectations higher because we
come from outside the u.s
let's let's discuss this one let's dig
into this one
yeah we we love uh busting these myths
and it
it it makes our our blood pressure go up
when we hear some of these notes
um i would say that the only difference
is that
english proficiency exam uh that you do
need to be fluent in english before you
get here and so yes
the you know i wouldn't say the bar is
higher but there is a
firm minimum on each of those three
english proficiency tests and you do
need to meet that minimum
uh and i i don't know christine that's
the only difference i can think of
i would agree because otherwise when
we're looking at the g
matter gre or the transcripts we're
looking at
everything exactly as we as we do for
every application
that we read looking for those same
instances or examples of intellectual
vitality and curiosity
and the context in which we consider how
people
ended up with the grades that they did
you know through all of the things
allison had mentioned earlier the majors
and
other things that might have been
happening outside all of that we look at
every application
in with the same kind of perspective so
it really is just those minimums that
again are set by stanford
and the reason those minimums are there
is because the the coursework here is
taught entirely in english
and again we do want to make sure that
people will not only be just kind of
getting by in the classroom but being
active participants
in the experience yeah and i would also
say that we
read a lot of international applications
so we also have a very good sense of
what some of the different academic um
kind of systems are um and also not
everybody is graded on the same scale
and so sometimes when people are trying
to translate
or do correlations i think there's a lot
that gets lost
in translation there i know there was
another question
of prior in the q a box
uh that had to do like what gpa do we
report do we
do it there it is do we use it for each
unique year
or do we use the cumulative at the end
of each year
so not all schools will do that report
what you
have and i would say report it in the
grading system and grading scale
that you attended we want to see how you
did in the context of your education
um and even within the american system i
could there's like
i've seen 4.0 scales i've seen 5.0
scales
i've see there are schools that don't
give us a grade
a letter or a number but there's a full
write-up for every course they've taken
those are fun to work through um so we
are very
comfortable with a wide range of these
systems
um but as both allison and christine
were saying like there is no different
standard that we hold for our
international candidates
um i think that context piece does play
come into play
sometimes the language element because
maybe your first second
and or maybe third or beyond languages
were not english
you know and that might pull down an
overall gmat score or make things look
different so
i would set that myth to rest we are
looking for the same criteria
and the same types of talent ability and
perspective or
a breadth of talent skills and
perspectives
diversity within diversity from all of
our applicants
no matter where they come from
all right question continuing on the
theme of
international and uh academics and other
contexts
if our transcripts aren't in english do
we need to have them translated
is it okay to translate them ourselves
how should someone approach that
yes when you send me copies of the
transcripts
uh oftentimes we may see both so we may
see the official
uh in your original language and then a
translated version
because despite our best efforts uh we
can't read all of the languages
but it is sometimes helpful to to see
both but
some of you sometimes people will use
different services
to do the translations um so there's
some flexibility when you're applying
because we're looking for copies of your
transcripts at this time
um but if admitted we will need to see
the official
transcripts and we will need an official
translated copy at that time
great thank you and kind of and so
you just mentioned can apply with an
unofficial transcript
we'll request an official one later i
know sometimes that has been
um a topic of conversation we understand
that sometimes requesting transcripts
costs additional money if you're
applying to many business schools
that might increase the cost so we're
really trying to be as sensitive as
possible um throughout this process
also knowing that sometimes it's just
really difficult to get official
transcripts
especially if maybe you haven't attended
school for a long time
there can be a lot of different hoops
you have to um jump through so we're
trying our best to
ease that process wherever we can
okay and here's here's another question
and i think it
tailors nicely with this question of
maybe i'm still doing some preparation
maybe there's things that i'm still
doing when should someone apply right
do like at what point should we be
thinking about
i need to have everything in my
application or what are things that it's
okay to update later on when does that
make sense
how should i be thinking about kind of
the two
possibilities out there yeah i mean of
course
obviously there's when you want to start
school which is probably the first cut
but then it's really when can you
present the strongest application
and you know when you update things
later
uh after the deadline they will become
part of your file but we can't promise
that they'll be considered we may have
already read your application
so i would say you know if you're
waiting for something
really important like uh well in fact
you know with the gmat if you're going
to retest
retake it or the gre score that does
need to be taken
before the deadline so um i would say
you know minor things could be updated
but if it's something really important
to the strength of your application
you'd want to do it before you apply
great thank you and here i let's round
into this question again
um kind of we've approached it from
different perspectives but i don't think
we've actually
named it so the question is
from someone who does not necessarily
have the broadest quant
background and maybe some of the obvious
places but
how can they communicate quantitative
abilities
do they always need to or like in what
spaces does it make sense
yeah i think allison um talked about
this a little bit earlier on
in that again if it doesn't naturally or
obviously present
in say your test score or in your
academic
background and experience the workplace
is is often times where this will
surface and
in some cases it might present because
you've told us in your resume
maybe you know one of the line items
under one of your your particular roles
or
in your time at a particular company
you're able to highlight a time when you
were working on something analytical
but another place where that surfaces a
lot for us is through the letters of
reference that we receive so your
recommenders may be able to
share stories with us about how you were
able to display some of those
quantitative or analytical skills
through
a different project that you might have
been working on
in the company so there's a lot of
different places and again
even sometimes in your extracurricular
activities so
um you may not be giving yourself enough
credit you may be a part of a community
organization and you had to organize
a big drive and it turns out that you
actually had to keep things really
organized and you were actually using
more of those kind of muscles than you
may have even realized
so there may be an opportunity to share
some of those stories within your
application as well
yeah maybe you're sharing some of that
in one of your written responses maybe
it's an
optional response maybe just a bullet
point or two in your additional
information if it doesn't
come up naturally somewhere else so we
really provide a lot of landscape for
you to use
in a way that makes sense for you um so
hopefully
if you take that if you're thinking
about it and you're like yes i do have
these but it doesn't
come out obviously my application let us
know in one of these other spaces
um i'll take one one more question that
i really want to ask our group
i have come across i've had a lot of
conversations about folks who
might not have had uh the most stellar
kind of initial undergraduate career and
then
redid or had these other um
kind of journeys and pathways that show
that they have these talents so
as we close out uh this the session
kind of can we crystallize in just a few
words like
how can you demonstrate like this
intellectual vitality across a broad
range like
any thoughts words of wisdom words of
encouragement that you have for folks
out there
who might still be hesitating because
you know
of a past that they have
i guess mine are just a little a few
reminders that you do
have that additional information section
if you do want to explain some
extenuating circumstances
and also that we look at um you know we
look at the whole journey so
you may have started out uh with a
weaker gpa
at the beginning of university and then
it got stronger
um or you may have done some graduate
work um
uh that that had you know showed
stronger
performance um and that um again you
know we look at other sources like your
workplace your
extracurriculars you know maybe you're
at a robotics club and my goodness
you've done a lot of
you know quantitative stuff
i'll i'll just kind of add on top of
what allison mentioned
um remembering that your academic
experience uh undergrad or graduate if
you've had any
again it's a it's a moment in time in in
your very long
life and journey and so if you didn't
perform as well in undergrad for
whatever reasons that might have been
uh knowing that you'll still have an
opportunity to demonstrate some of that
intellectual vitality through
the the testing process that could be an
opportunity for you to make sure you're
spending enough time studying and
preparing
so you have an opportunity to show what
we may not have been able to see earlier
uh if you're one of those folks out
there who worry about testing that's not
your strong suit i understand i hear you
and just know that if you are coming in
maybe with a lower gmat or gre
and lower grades again that additional
information
is a section where you can share some of
that context the rest of the story to
fill in those pieces for us
and again just know that we are looking
at everything else that you've done in
your life beyond those
two things uh to try to get again a full
understanding of who you are and what
you have to contribute to this community
and i love how we've kind of zoomed out
through this process to really think
high level
my words of encouragement are you are so
much
more than two numbers
in an application there is the journey
as part of that journey is that learning
and growth that you have
have earned over your time you know if
you're thinking about
business school who are you now because
of those
uh experiences what are some of the
skill sets that
you now have so that you can thrive when
you are in a
moment of challenge again what are some
of the things that
do spark your excitement to learn grow
and in turn share that knowledge with
others i think
as we kind of step back and really think
about the wholeness of who you
are the academic piece is just one
part of the story and i really encourage
you
if you aren't already check out our
sharing your story workshop series where
we'll be able to unpack even more about
how you can think about these elements
and moments in your life
such that you can really put your best
foot forward whether it's in a written
format in the application
an interview networking or any other
place where people are trying to learn
more about you and you're building
relationships
um kind of to move your career and life
forward
with that if you haven't done so i
encourage i also encourage you i'm doing
a lot of encouraging today apparently
i encourage you to start at my
stanford.mba
account we can um with a couple
questions we'll can help you create a
dashboard
that'll consolidate events of interest
to you
there's also an application of tracker
that'll help you
keep track of where you are in the
process to make sure you're headed
in the right way for that round one
round two or round three deadline
with that thank you so much for joining
us today hopefully we're able to share
some
good information things that help you
better understand
how we use testing transcripts and your
overall academic history
to better understand who you are in this
application process
hopefully i'll see you around throughout
the rest of this week or at other
stanford events
until then take care and stay safe